[Música]
un cordial saludo mi nombre es Ángela
Gómez y bienvenidos a esta misión
especiales con las buenas noticias del
año empezamos con una buena noticia para
los derechos en Estados Unidos derecho
Bing el oficial de policía que asesino
George Floyd fue declarado culpable en
abril por los cargos de homicidio y
asesinato en segundo grado la decisión
fue recibida con beneplácito por la
comunidad afroamericana que acusa a la
policía de excesos y de racismo antes
Granadillo nos amplia
justicia para George Floyd EEUU
sentencia 22 años a dirección por
asesinar al afroamericano las imágenes
de su muerte dieron la vuelta al mundo
en un vídeo amateur se vio a Floyd
inmovilizado en el suelo diciendo
repetidamente no puedo respirar su
asaltante el policía chovi lo mantuvo
con su rodilla en el cuello durante 9
minutos y veintinueve segundos pero
muy brevemente quiero dar mis
condolencias a la familia Floyd
espero que esto les de un poco de
tranquilidad
el violento asesinato de Floyd provocó
protestas durante meses en todo Estados
Unidos contra la brutalidad policial y
la injusticia racial personalidades
afroamericanas como los Obama
reaccionaron a la condena hoy un jurado
hizo lo correcto pero la verdadera
justicia requiere mucho más también lo
hizo Oprah Winfrey
se declaró culpable hoy después de
someter a esta familia a un juicio
desgarrador en el que el jurado se dio
cuenta muy rápidamente de que era
culpable de todos los cargos
policía
debilitar la relación de Washington con
el presidente reyes de allí perdón en
Ankara
el año 2021 ha tenido un despliegue sin
precedentes de las energías renovables o
energía limpia en el mundo la Agencia
Internacional de la Energía pronóstico
que podría haber un aumento del 60%
hasta 2026 con China a la cabeza a pesar
de la buena noticia muchas preguntas
surgen sobre cómo será el Plan
Energético de los países en las próximas
décadas y sobre como su financiamiento
informe de Andrea Amaya
verde alternativa Olimpia son varios los
adjetivos para hablar de la energía
renovable el último informe de la
Agencia Internacional de la Energía
asegura que ese recurso tuvo una
expansión en 2021 de un 3% respecto a
2020 con 290 GW de nueva capacidad
instalada lo que supone un récord la
nueva economía global de la energía está
la Elsa sin embargo los retos son
grandes
según la Agencia durante los próximos
cinco años será China el país que
encabeza la capacidad instalada de
energías renovables con el 43% del
crecimiento global seguida por Europa
Estados Unidos e India si bien el futuro
de las energías verdes es aplaudido por
muchos los gobiernos deben esforzarse
más para cumplir con las metas adoptadas
en la COP 26 entre ellas la limitación
del calentamiento global a 1,5 grados
centígrados y la neutralidad de carbono
para 2050
para alcanzar esto Birol asegura que
habrá que doblar las capacidades
instaladas de energía renovable entre
2021 y 2026 y además la demanda mundial
de biocombustibles y de calefacción
procedente de fuentes limpias tendría
que crecer hasta cuatro veces más que lo
dicho en el informe
en España ya pueden pedir la eutanasia a
quienes tengan una enfermedad grave o
incurable el 25 de junio entro en
vigencia la ley que permite a los
pacientes que padecen un sufrimiento
físico o psíquico constante e
intolerable decidir entre recibir
atención para mejorar su calidad de vida
o solicitar una muerte digna la Nación
se convirtió en la séptima del mundo en
legalizar la medida que ya fue incluida
en la cartera básica del sistema
nacional de salud y que recibirá
financiación pública
y seguimos con temas de salud del
Instituto de Investigación en Lerner de
la Clínica Cleveland en Estados Unidos
desarrolla una vacuna contra el cáncer
de mama los investigadores empezaron a
inscribir a pacientes a para un primer
ensayo el medicamento está diseñado para
atacar el cáncer de seno triple negativo
uno de los más agresivos
robo entrevies una diseñadora Siria de
29 años en 2019 le descubrieron un
cáncer de seno estaba un tratamiento de
ese entonces perdió todo su cabello no
soportaba la idea hasta que decidió
aceptar su nueva identidad
cuando me miró en el espejo veo alguien
fuerte
pero es cierto que tampoco me veo
extraño mi antiguo yo
que sufren de cáncer de senos una vacuna
propuesta por un grupo de científicos
del Instituto de Investigación
del
desarrollo tras 20 años de investigación
la vacuna será ensayada de mujeres que
ya han sido diagnosticadas con cáncer de
mama triple negativo uno de los más
agresivos y tratadas con diferentes
tipos de terapias en la primera fase las
voluntarias recibirán 3 dosis de la
vacuna experimental una cada dos semanas
mientras se si hay una respuesta
inmunitaria el oncólogo estamos voz
principal investigador del proyecto dijo
a largo plazo muéstrame determinar si
está vacuna es capaz de combatir el
cáncer de seno especialmente en sus
variantes más agresivas antes de que
ocurra de tener éxito podría convertirse
en una terapia preventiva eficaz incluso
para personas sanas según cifras de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud en 2020
2,3 millones de mujeres en el mundo
fueron diagnosticadas con cáncer de mama
de las cuales 685000 fallecieron por
esta enfermedad a finales de noviembre
se celebró la comunidad diversa de
Botswana tras ganar una larga batalla
por despenalizar la homosexualidad el
Tribunal Superior fallo contra el
gobierno que había apelado la decisión
histórica de 2019 la homosexualidad
estaba prohibida desde
1965 con penas de hasta 7 años de
prisión Lesotho Mozambique Angola y
Seychelles también están entre los pocos
países África que han despenalizado las
relaciones del mismo sexo
está sentencia es realmente
impresionante porque va a cambiar la
vida de muchas personas en nuestro país
es realmente una oportunidad para que la
comunidad LGBT y reivindica su humanidad
y cambié el statu quo en nuestro país
en julio Argentina dio un paso en favor
de las personas no binarias el país cuyo
movimiento LGBT IQ más es muy poderoso
se convirtió en la primera nación Latina
en incluir una X en el documento de
identidad de las personas que no se
identifican como femenina o masculina
este decreto se inscribe en una política
y que quiere favorecer la diversidad y
la libre elección de los ciudadanos
y terminamos en la alfombra roja este
año 2021 fue particularmente prolífico
para las mujeres en el cine desde can
hasta Los Ángeles en abril la Academia
de los Óscar dio a la china Chloe Zhao
la estatuilla a mejor directora porno
más un doble reconocimiento por ser la
primera asiática y la segunda mujer en
obtener el máximo galardón la británica
Emerald Fennell obtuvo mejor guión
original por una joven prometedora firme
que además se presenta un camino de
venganza contra el abuso sexual en julio
el Festival de Cannes premio a su
segunda mujer como mejor directora en su
historia la francesa Julia no se llevó
la palma de oro en
septiembre
chica con nosotros en France 24
[Música]